Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this is my
Korra Episode 5 video.
Kuvira turned a big corner and Korra is back
in action.
It’s like the eye of the storm.
Korra went through hell to fix herself, now
it’s that really pregnant pause before everything
goes insane again.
Quick reminder, new round of the giveaway
starts now, all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment.
Careful for spoilers if you’re not caught
up.
Zhu Li, do the Top 5 moments thing.
I really need to hire a zhu li of my own.
Number 5 - Varrick’s Superweapon
I’m totally not suprised it turned out to
be a weapon of mass destruction.
Varrick’s speechifying reminded me of the
original Manhattan Project.
Especially with the way he was filming himself,
chronicling his progress.
You can think of this as a wink back at the
movers from book 2.
We got all the Nuktuk stuff in book 3 so maybe
when they’re all done Bolin will retire
and start making them again.
The animation effect on it looked just like
the energy blasts Korra and UnaVaatu were
giving off during the book 2 finale.
Varrick has accidentally replicated the power
of energy benders in a way.
Energy Bending is way more complicated than
just blasting people.
But it’s capable of causing Avatar levels
of Destruction.
That does not make Kuvira the new Dark Avatar
though.
But I would pay good money to see that Cosplay.
Who else was proud of Varrick for trying to
put the brakes on it too.
I think we all knew what was going to happen
the minute the blast went off.
Kuvira would try to take advantage of it.
For now he’s stuck working on it.
Mixed up in all this is the Varrick Zhu-Li
subplot.
Which of course leads me to
Number 4 - Zhu Li Turns a big corner
Korra and Kuvira are the two lead characters
in the episode, but Zhu Li was the biggest
badass.
And yes, I know everyone is wondering what’s
up with her turning sides at the end.
I think that’s all bullcrap.
She’s already shown herself to be smarter
and a better fighter than Varrick, so it stands
to reason that she’s also better at manipluation.
I think she just said all that so that she
could stay and protect Varrick.
I am hoping they’ll have some fun with the
character and make her pretend to be bad for
another episode or two before she saves Varrick
again and helps him escape.
She also got the best line in the episode.
They gave her Varrick’s line “Guards Do
The Thing!”
She and Varrick have a weird relationship,
the almost kiss was high on my list too.
I think they’ll seal the deal before the
end of the season.
Number 3 - Suyin’s Flashback
It’s nice they included this, I think we
all had a pretty good idea of what went down
between them though.
They had that scene back in Republic City
where Kuvira called her out for sitting on
her butt when the Earth Kingdom was in chaos.
I actually thought explaining what was up
with P’tar Junior’s crazy hate of his
family was all about.
He was nuts in this episode.
Even Kuvira had to tell him to chill.
She told Suyin she didn’t brainwash him,
which of course means she brainwashed the
crap out of him.
Not Dai Li brainwashed, she just whispered
in his ear.
She’s also probably using all the sex they’re
having to cloud his judgement.
I know we haven’t seen any Kuvira sex scenes.
Even though I’m sure they exist on tumblr.
But just because they haven’t shown them
doesn’t mean no one is having sex.
I’m sure the world of Avatar is very traditional,
but you heard Kuvira, “she always gets what
she wants.”
That’s not important to the episode, I just
think it’s funny to pry open the characters
lives when we don’t see them on screen.
Number 2 - Kuvira is pours Bolin all of the
Metal Kool-Aide
For those that don’t get the kool-aide reference,
there was a crazy religious cult a long time
ago that brainwashed all the members and made
them drink poisoned kool-aide in this weird
suicide ritual.
Of course Bolin figures out what’s going
on.
There’s no way we’re going to start the
second half of the season without Team Korra
all being on the same side.
I know Mako and Asami are back in Republic
City but we still have another couple weeks
before we pass the halfway mark.
I was surprised they didn’t do much with
Bolin during the negotiation.
He did have that speech but the minute Kuvira
walked in the door Suyin already had her mind
made up, so it was all pointless.
The Mech Battle was amazing.
The trailer didn’t do it justice.
Zhu Li has been holding out on us.
She isn’t a bender but I see her as an Asami
character.
Someone who is really smart and a good fighter.
So of course she can pilot the mech.
If you didn’t catch it, Bryke explained
during Comic Con that the Mechs look different
based on the rank they are.
Like military ranks.
So I believe the Green ones are of a higher
rank.
I think they’re all the same structurally
though.
We also learned Lava Bending is very effective
against them.
The mintue Bolin lava bended those two they
went down instantly.
So just remember that.
It’s like Mako lightning bending Ming Hua
in book 3.
Just instant takedown.
As for the re-education camps, don’t you
feel like the Dai Li would be the camp counselors
there.
Re-education of course being brainwashing.
When Kuvira said she was sending Zhu-Li there
too all I could think of was Joo De.
I think there names being so similar sounding
is just a coincidence though.
and my Number 1 moment - Korra and Kuvira
get ready to throw down.
Korra gave her a chance, now it’s time to
kick some butt.
After she saves Suyin and her sons.
That was the big WTF at the end.
Suyin had taken her twin sons and it sounded
like they were going to capture Kuvira.
Potentially very bad PR move.
Kuvira is playing it smart.
She even said all the world’s eyes are on
us.
So Suyin attacking will be all she needs to
launch a full scale assault.
I love how Suyin treated Korra kind of like
Zhu Li too.
Korra do the Avatar thing.
Theoretically Korra would be able to earthbend
a giant hand to just swat all the mechs like
flies.
But she and Kuvira had such a classic Gunslinger
standoff I feel like it would be a huge bummer
if they didn’t face off against each other.
That wouldn’t be the smartest way to defeat
her, Korra needs to learn to play the game
of thrones.
She needs Cersei Lannister to teach her politics.
Also it didn’t really fit into my top 5
moments, but Asami with her father was really
big.
The actor that plays Hiroshi Sato said he
came back to do scenes a long time ago, so
we knew he was going to be here.
We just didn’t know what his role would
be.
It seems like based on what’s going on between
P’tar Junior and his father, Asami’s scenes
were all about healing family relationships
and forgiveness.
That’s going to be a big throughline for
all the characters this season.
Forgiveness.
So just remember that when it comes time for
a final battle between Korra and Kuvira in
the last couple of episodes.
Forgive each other and play some pai sho.
And maybe cry a little because this is the
last season.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
and do you think everyone will be able to
forgive Kuvira after she goes crazy with that
superweapon.
I felt like it was heavily implied that Kuvira
would use it and that would be the minute
the world turns on her.
You don’t place a gun on the table before
a fight if you don’t plan on using it.
If any of you are theater geeks, there’s
this thing called Chekov’s Gun, “One must
never place a rifle on the stage if it’s
not going to go off.”
- so just plan on that giant spirit vine rifle
going off
Which is actually a good transition to my
review.
I gave the episode an A just because it was
such a big turning point for all the characters
and in the shuffle they focused on very under-developed
characters.
Zhu Li just got so much more interesting.
P’tar Junior is the whiny son with no self-esteem,
so yes, it’s annoying to listen to him whine
about how hard it was growing up rich and
famous.
I’m sure all the poor people in Ba Sing
Se really give a shit about all that.
I feel like if a character can’t be someone
you admire, they might as well be someone
you can really really hate.
That’s why I think Bryke wrote him being
so vicious in that Mech battle.
If you’re going to be bad, be very bad.
Don’t half ass being evil.
Somewhere off in the distance Azula is laughing
at him.
I’m totally not surprised when Korra episodes
are this good, I still think Toph and Korra
from episode 3 is the best episode so far.
Mostly because it’s such fanservice.
So Q&A posting tomorrow morning.
The Doctor Who Season finale is happening
then too so I’ll try to post that next Korra
video early.
Sometimes I don’t finish it fast enough.
Right now click here to get that.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it and Click here for Korra Episode 4.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and i’ll see you tonight!